CATHERINE DRENNAN:
The first thing
I do when I'm getting
ready for the class is
to go over the handouts and
make sure they're really
what I want, update
them, and go over that.
Then I usually have-- sort
of back to my theater days,
I guess-- a plan
for the lecture.
When the clicker
questions are going to be,
what I'm showing on PowerPoint
presentation, what I'm going
to be writing on the board.
And so I have it all organized.
There is times when I want
to ask them a question
and how I'm going to do that.
If we're going to have a demo
in that particular class,
where it's going to fit in,
how it's going to be set up.
And I like to bring-- I love
three dimensional things.
So if we're talking about
bonding, I want giant atoms
and I'm always trying
to think of things
that I can bring in
to use to show someone
some kind of concept.
And so I want, at
least once a week,
to have some kind of
demo in the class.
It's nice.
I also like some geeky science
music and other things.
And then, in the last
year where I taught,
I upped the bar for myself.
So if people are watching the
most current OpenCourseWare,
they will see my
t-shirt collection.
So I decided that in
addition to thinking
about the demos and
the songs and what
I'm writing on
the board and when
I'm going to ask questions
and all of these things,
that I needed to coordinate
it with my wardrobe.
So that was a high bar
that I set for myself.
And that somehow the
t-shirt not only had
to be some kind of
geeky chemistry thing
but related, somehow,
to the topic at hand.
So that was one of-- that
took a lot of preparation.
I had to plan.
So if I had to order t-shirts,
I had to order ahead of time
so they arrived.
And figuring out a different
t-shirt per lecture,
that was one of the
harder challenges.